[Music]
miami florida known for its beautiful
people sandy beaches and latin inspired
culture
an ideal place for a
danish restaurant what is traditional
danish
yeah
food
lot of people don't understand that andy
and his wife suzanne purchased the
successful restaurant fleming a taste of
denmark eight years ago we knew it was a
good restaurant we knew it was very
popular and the whole idea for us was to
try and keep it as much the same as
possible so there would be little change
other than someone else greeting them at
the front door hi welcome to flemington
how are you we were worried about the
fact that it said fleming a taste of
denmark neither one of us know much
about scandinavian food it doesn't have
celery and it doesn't
we struggled to try and find a chef to
come in very knowledgeable in danish
cuisine we finally found something we
like
[Music]
orlando is a classically trained
chef very danish food today huh i'm from
cuba and the menu right now it's not 100
of my cuisine give me flavor on the food
flavor i prefer something like when you
right away you eat your food just you
feel it what is that
bam you're gonna have to start learning
how to speak danish
i have this chef who's got lots of ideas
you know let's change this let's change
that but i've been very reluctant
because i you know i don't want to
alienate our regular loyal customers
[Music]
follow me ladies yes our clientele that
comes to the restaurant are old people
[Music]
all the servers they read the obituaries
to see if our customers are listed on
there after a while it's pretty sad when
you see them sort of knocking down like
dominoes so i haven't been here for a
while because of health situations
well i'm glad you're feeling better yeah
and that's just sad to know these are
the only people that we've served to
keeps going like it's been going this is
what we got 15 years ago you couldn't
get in here on a friday or saturday
night because it was booked now we don't
even have reservations to fill our
friday and saturday night i think we
have to change something we'll talk
about it later
andy has been afraid to make changes and
why you know when i tell andy well i
want to do this and i want to do that
and he says that's not going to fly you
can't worry just about what the old
farts think that come into your
restaurant
you got to get in the younger people and
the middle-aged people that are going to
be your clients for the next 10 years
it's a 31 dinner
the huge amount of debt that we're under
right now it puts a strain on the
restaurant it puts a strain on
relationship i have with with employees
it puts a strain on my relationship at
home with suzanne this business sucks i
know we can't have many more saturday
nights like this
or we're not going to stay in business
our restaurant and our home mortgage are
tied into one loan i'm concerned about
losing our house
this has been one of the most stressful
years of my life
we're at a point where we need this
restaurant to be successful soon or or
we're going to be in
big trouble
people immigrate to america to chase the
great american dream they come from
sicily to open the most amazing italian
restaurants from shanghai to open their
chinese restaurants this is the first
time i've ever been to a danish
restaurant can't wait to meet the danish
immigrants thank goodness i brought my
dictionary
hi good to see you welcome to fleming
jordan please and your first name is
suzanne suzanne and i'm andy andy good
to see you you're the owners yes yes
okay great
vodan erdu
i'm sorry
no danish here
it's a danish restaurant the danes have
left the building so
[Music]
the chef's english no no he's cuban
human
cuban and the name fleming's what it
means fleming is was the original owner
of the restaurant because he's there
so i'm trying to get my head around this
danish name what's danish in the
restaurant there's still some influence
on food and we kept everything almost
identical
oh what's going on with the color
somebody color blind oh yeah yeah
actually i am good you are yeah well you
look very well coordinated in terms of
dresses
right where should i sit i'll take you
in
what are they there those are our
desserts we put them out every day why
would you put them out before the
customer orders them so they can choose
so you finish your entree and then you
parade up here to the gallery uh-huh
this is antiquated this idea this was
the way fleming did it it's been kept
this way seriously does that look
appetizing adjacent to the bathroom door
they all have to walk by it at some
point during the evening trust me if i
was on my way to the bathroom and i had
to bypass that
i'd be discouraged to come back and
order dessert
i better sit down
dessert museum
maybe when you taste some things will be
better
good evening how are you good austin how
are you i'm fine i'm julie i'll be your
servant excellent this is the crew that
day we serve with every meal well i'm
the crew today since uh my granddad's
80th birthday so old-fashioned and how
long have you been here i've been here
15 years
so you were with the old owners yes i
was wow what's changed here in 15 years
the staff
wow my god
and did the original russian fleming's
have pink honestly pink flowers pink
napkins pink walls it's pink everywhere
yeah
oh good grief the pink walls and little
blue plates to me it's almost antique
it's like walking into grandma's house
oh it's like goodbye to grandma
think i'm ready let's start off with
the uh gravel axe okay
gotta see that frickadella certainly
entree i'll go for the grandfather duck
and daniels okay excellent thank you
[Music]
i have one grab black one free appetizer
you tell me what you know really about
the food from denmark i don't know too
much for me it's not very excited i
prefer something like it when you put
your food in your mouth you have pot in
your mouth
here's your garage locks wow
take me around the plates um it's just
some garnish and then you have the uh
grav locks thank you line
wow
[Music]
that is hideous tastes like flight paper
oh jesus
there's a nice fly in the side of my
plate as well
what a shame that tastes very strange
way overdone and unfortunately the fly
he's dead now anyway okay
oh my god he absolutely hated this and
there was a bug on there
garbage
[Music]
one free appetizer
and this is our homemade ricadellas
well thank you
frick adella
[Music]
jesus
it's just often mushy
does the chef ever seen food
everything's just got this air of
blandness it's just like mush and just
disintegrates that's our customers
unbelievable they must be a lot easier
on the dentures yes
[Music]
so far not so good
my name's david how's everything so far
dreadful
is it special for you
there's a swan just appeared on that
lady's table over there what is that
cindy does there what is that for cindy
uh she has a tiramisu in it let's have a
little look at that
look this is from the old day oh my
goodness me that is extraordinary though
i'm gonna order dessert just to get the
swan huh how cool is that
enjoy
it's amazing it reminds me of my sixth
birthday party with my family you must
show me how to do that okay oh yes
i like to make my swans and take them to
the people and see their reaction
just take a big piece of foil just fold
it over enough room to have a nice big
tail we love a big tail
more elegant like you glamorous oh bless
you
twist it around
i love it make him a pretty little head
it's just about it wow oh and the kids
love it
this is special for you here thank you
very much my children will love it thank
you very much
thank you thank you excellent let me
just make that day if this doesn't work
out i'll certainly go to work for chef
ramsey i'll make all his swans
[Music]
this is the dust
my goodness me when was that cooked just
now really it looks like it was roasted
a couple of days ago
thank you
well
not even moist
jesus just when you think
it couldn't get any worse
i don't think that grandpappy wanted
duck cooked like that that's definitely
one [ __ ] up
[Music]
right now i didn't even think a swan
would cheer me up
oh god
[Music]
he didn't like it
[Music]
wow 1992.
tell the chef i surrender
no more please
god bless denmark
we're done
son of a [ __ ]
what a disaster
[Music]
where's the chef that way straight
behind the line
hello
how are you i'm very good i'm very good
and you're the head chef here yes sir
why is everything so bland
that's some of the worst food i've ever
eaten the gravel acts why is it so tough
i don't have an answer for that it's
like eating a leather belt
fricatella mushy the duck was dry
overcooked
that was shocking
honestly the food is so outdated why'd
you let him cook that food because we
haven't tried to change the menu we've
won we just
haven't tried to change anything
just been afraid to change my god you're
nostalgic with something that's not
worked for a long time
you are at the end of the line
good evening how are you
word of chef ramsay's arrival has filled
the restaurant with customers for the
first time in five years and so tonight
the entire fleming staff owners waiters
and cooks will be tested
follow me please
i am disappointed at some of the things
that happened today how's everything
going out here good i just need to start
sitting this room now okay but there's
nowhere to go but up now and i trust
andy 100
and i hoped it got him right because if
i'm not we're [ __ ] out of luck
my name is julie i'll be your server
this evening gentlemen have you decided
i really don't know something danish
obviously the grandfather duck drama the
wiener special kids working in beautiful
wine denny's chicken i'm winner
i need cindy please
just 30 minutes into service and a
number of entrees have left the kitchen
perfection that's what you got dinner's
ready
so clearly speed is not a problem at
fleming
they're pretty awful
however satisfying customers is
how is everything this isn't so good
okay this isn't so good
i'm not gonna do that
thank you i appreciate it
i couldn't even look at that
needed it's thick and bland you're glad
to blend yeah
it just doesn't taste very good
okay i let him know 53 hated this okay
okay what didn't he like about this you
just said he hated it he said he can't
eat it
i'll bring you the menu ma'am so you can
choose something else and i'll get you
another picnole salmon thank you thank
you
andy oh no come on this is mushy andy is
absolutely afraid of change he's tried
to keep the tradition and i think it's
time to move on
[ __ ]
i need some extra salt salsas to dry
what a disaster
come
oh
on
it's a non-stop parade of food being
returned to the kitchen you know that
yes
almost everything coming back was bland
doesn't taste well and tastes good
what's going on with it
no flavor three
items oh [ __ ] those dishes were all
danish style items that have been there
for 25 years can i get you something
else to eat you're just eating bread
that's not gonna help
chicken was totally bland i don't see
how anything can get worse at this point
while andy tries to pacify unhappy
diners i can make something like
coconut shrimp very quickly crab cakes
chef ramsay has seen enough of the
kitchen in action he's heard the
complaints about the food and knows that
many of the problems are not caused by
cooking alone holy mackerel
[Music]
but by what is lurking in the storage
unit
[Music]
mashed potatoes piping
hot this is unbelievable andy suzanne
come in here
oh gosh
orlando i know you're busy there big boy
i just need it for 30 seconds please
yeah i'll be quick come with me so this
is for raw meat yes and here we got some
what the [ __ ] is that
oh my god no come on oh my god oh [ __ ]
there was one duck on a tray with meat
that was thawing and the duck was in the
meat juice cook duck and defrosting me
look at it there's a who put the ducks
there then ah [ __ ] we've been selling
duck
[Music]
stop the kitchen everybody
i need all the ducks off the table and
stop them eating it they have
discontinued the dog no just for this
evening
table 61 had duck is that the dark
i'm so sorry i'll explain two seconds do
excuse me
it was embarrassing to have chef ramsay
literally take the duck from in front of
the gentleman and tell everybody no duck
[Music]
have you served anybody doc i've served
about eight
stop
we're not serving another [ __ ] duck
out there we just contaminated the whole
[ __ ] place
oh my gosh oh my god draw me now and
cook meat no come on a frightening
discovery in the storage unit stop
we're not serving another [ __ ] duck
out there we just contaminated the whole
place has clearly shown chef ramsay just
how far this once legendary restaurant
has followed now i am seriously
seriously worried
yeah you're right you're [ __ ] if i was
a health inspector now what would you do
you would take that product and probably
throw it out
throw it out you can continue serving
one more plate of food what do you think
we're gonna do continue cooking i don't
believe that the food that's out here
now is contaminated
i never have seen that before if i did i
would have a fit but i was surprised
that andy wasn't aware of that i think
he's had his head buried in the sand for
the last seven years
one more thing
i'm [ __ ] out of it
there are blinders at times when things
get tough i put them on and i just forge
ahead and you miss some things and we
missed some of those
chef ramsay is frustrated by andy's
laid-back attitude so he decides to try
and get some answers from andy's wife
suzanne
i don't know where to start
okay
i don't know what to tell you all i can
say is i'm sorry
trying to work with an owner that's in
denial
is ten times harder why is he so blase
[Music]
i think he's probably in shock i don't
know i'm not him so i don't know what
he's doing right now
suzanne if your husband
doesn't start realizing what he's doing
wrong in a big way
i can't help it i agree i agree
i feel let down by andy this is a huge
huge wake-up call and if this doesn't
make any change nothing will i don't
know where to start suzanne
what i do know is that right now i don't
feel too good about this one
[Music]
a dramatic change in the weather and
that's exactly what fleming's needs a
big dramatic change so i'm going to hit
the streets and find out what the locals
really want from their fleming's
restaurant
hello hi good to see you guys now ladies
have you heard of fleming's yeah nobody
talks about it anymore nobody says oh i
was at fleming's let's go back and try
it out there's a new owner and it went
downhill have you heard the fleming's
restaurant actually i have what's the
word on the streets not so good food my
parents used to go there back in the day
when it was good but i didn't even know
it's still open i haven't heard any good
reviews it's old yeah it's uh it's a
place my mom and dad would probably love
to go and you're not gonna go anywhere
near the place again not until
something's done it's extraordinary and
these guys at first have changed but you
got all those customers standing on your
doorstep
unbelievable
so sad
chef ramsay's grassroots research
clearly points out how damaged this
restaurant's reputation really is
ironically many of the people who work
at fleming realize they are in desperate
need of change
but there is one person who doesn't
agree with that
unfortunately it's the owner
yesterday was a really bad day i took
the morning this morning walked around
the community done my homework and
really
confirmed this
danish restaurant
is no longer talk of the town
so what i need from each and every one
of you is to be incredibly honest
let's talk about what's wrong with the
restaurants
orlando tell andy what this place needs
i believe we need to build a new menu we
need to build in new food something more
attractive something more
contemporary you know
that's my opinion right now
crystal tell andy why direction's not
working
you're scared you're gonna fail
so instead of taking the jump and the
leap of actually doing what you want to
do you're scared
that no one's gonna like it and you're
gonna lose everything but the truth of
the matter is and either way you're
gonna lose it if you don't do something
suzanne
you and i spent time talking last night
you were pissed off tell your husband
what he needs to do to get this place
back on track
in my opinion i think a lot of people
are afraid of change
and they don't change until they're
brought down to their knees because
they're terrified because it's easier to
stay with what they know than to risk
change and i think
that has been andy's fault
do you understand what she's saying yeah
i i her points are valid my how do you
respond to it how my response to it now
is
i'm just afraid to alienate the people
that we had and lose what we have
the only thing right now
that's going to save your business
is a dramatic change
it's a long time coming and it's it's
time to do it
and he needs to take ownership of the
restaurant and i think andy will buck up
now and take charge get ready
for a dramatic change
[Music]
chef ramsay knows that the changes to
fleming cannot be subtle and the most
drastic change needs to be the food
so step one of his plan is to take the
restrictions off the kitchen
and let them cook
i want to spend the next 20 minutes
looking at the ingredients what we've
got and just cooking something and when
you start
forget anything to do with danish people
don't go out in south florida to dine
danish let's get that right yeah okay
think popular think trend and think
where we are okay let's do some good
four of us together yes
i want to see a little bit of flair
oh yeah baby that's gonna be awesome
something different ah
that's like what we're looking for
that's like we're ready for that a
student is beautiful is it mounting you
now
let's go ready
with the shackles taken off the kitchen
have come up with a number of exciting
non-danish menu items that's definitely
not our menu
jeff ramsey has added a seer tuna
now to make sure everyone is on the same
page he shares these new dishes with the
front of the house staff
scrumptious
excellent nothing danish there taste the
chips that'd be seasoned a little bit of
cayenne pepper
black beans
pineapple salsa yeah this is so good
and i love this seeing those dishes and
tasting them it's a better reflection of
what miami is and i think it'll draw in
a big crowd very nice
very nice i think change is difficult
for everybody what we've been doing for
the same 25 years is not working anymore
we're gonna get this restaurant on track
[Music]
with chef ramsay's newfound belief in
the kitchen staff and andy gordon his
team worked through the night to pull
off one of the most ambitious makeovers
yet
good morning
good morning come through please all
right
today is about
dramatic changes andy suzanne are you
ready absolutely yes good let's go
it's time to enter the new fleming and
more importantly time to start a new
profitable chapter
oh yeah come in
oh please oh god
holy cow can you believe this
oh my god
this is magic
we've got that pink that scares and
spooks customers away it was dated and
uninviting now it's warm it's elegant it
brings in a new modern era i'm so
excited for annie and suzanne it's the
direction that we've been wanting to go
and now we can take those baby steps to
do that because we can't go back to
being the old flemings
this color is gorgeous andy what color
is it i'm not sure you're not sure okay
that looks great
it's a tudor brown we've got some new
art on the walls and look at the lights
they make the brown stand out and have a
look at this oh look at that
i can talk this is no longer johansen
fleming's restaurant a wonderful new
theme birds of flight taking off into
new chapters a new beginning i love it
i'm extremely happy it's gorgeous to see
andy and suzanne crying for happy
we haven't seen that in a long time
nothing but grim faces nothing but
despair and this is not despair this is
awesome i want to just bust amazing
i don't cry very often i can't tell you
the last time
i this did it this is uh
everything for us
it gives us new hope you okay yeah i'm
good i'm good
i'm crazy for you i'm so happy for you
to see my husband cry with happiness
to me that was the biggest gift of all
i've never seen him so happy it's been a
huge wake-up call for him now we have a
russian to be proud of to take us right
in to the 21st century andy embrace it
really convict it make it yours it will
happen
with the change in decor now complete
chef ramsay's next step in turning
around the business is to market the
restaurant to a younger clientele
so he reaches out to two local designers
and puts together a swimsuit fashion
show oh wow
wow
the fashion show was fabulous i was
amazed
it's good to see younger faces that we
want to attract to the restaurant the
people are very excited our phones are
probably ringing off the hook although
the main objective of the fashion show
was to spread the word about the new
fleming chef ramsay had a secret mission
that he wanted to reveal
weren't they amazing
for the grand finale please welcome our
male model
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
it's andy the owner of fleming's
restaurant
i was in shock because i didn't really
quite recognize him it was more than a
breath of fresh air there's a whole
hurricane it's exactly yeah
10 years younger
yes you look great honey the clothes
were amazing the haircut was amazing
most importantly he was smiling how can
you not be motivated give it up buddy
well done yes you look great feel good
i'm ready to go you got to come see this
new restaurant it is unbelievable
[Music]
it's hours before relaunch and with the
dining room makeover and owner makeover
now complete okay rylander let's go
buddy chef ramsay is ready to unveil the
new fleming menu gonna the danish gravel
axe the fricadel
and the grandfather duck and in its
place a modern contemporary menu ideally
suited for south miami right start off
with the crab cakes yeah a modern twist
the rock shrimp lettuce cups pan seared
group of fillets seasoned with chorizo
so it's a little bit spicy playing on
the cuban influence because the chef is
cuban and more importantly nice contrast
yeah they look more contemporary
definitely more like this century you
know before we're not in this century we
go back to the 80s you know
look at the portion size what i want to
see tonight more than anything is empty
plates because when desserts come
we're going to do this
very very simple ah yeah
to the table
[Applause]
it looks so inviting it's modern
contemporary and it's just an immaculate
way of serving a dessert we don't stand
and hold on to nostalgia we move on
andy how does it look it looks fabulous
chef huh now there's no excuse
have a little taste yeah we're opening
in just under an hour guys yeah
um
that was good that is
out of this world the menu is fantastic
the food tasted out great everything
looks wonderful unbelievable i didn't
see any danish food anywhere
[Music]
fleming has gone through some major
changes in the last 72 hours it appears
as though the biggest change may have
been the owner andy okay 74 75 77 78 no
76 okay who has a newfound energy and is
operating like the leader he once was
let's go we gotta roll chef ramsay
definitely put a fire under andy you
should have everything out there he was
sent down special from heaven i know he
is
tonight relaunch night yes it's gonna be
difficult but stick together we're not
throwing food out we're carrying
seasoning and hitting perfection okay
yes sir
let's go i'm feeling nervous excited
tense
everything everything all at once
crystal
tichuan cook from the miami heat yeah
he's coming for dinner okay so look
after me
hi welcome to fleming's the fashion show
clearly has spread the word about
fleming this is our new menu i like the
look it's very clean and it's refreshing
i'm very excited enjoy dinner thanks the
restaurant is fully booked my name is
crystal thank you
are you ready to order yeah i'm gonna
get it like a house salad can i try the
wood salad oh i'm gonna have the pancake
yes mia the pesto shrimp lip greetings
first table yes two small caesar salad
snap on it big boy
as part of the new menu all the entrees
come with either a house salad a wedge
salad or a caesar salad
15 minutes into service and the salads
are leaving the kitchen
[Music]
rich you got to be quick with those
things caesar's coming with croutons are
they coming with vegetables
vegetables he's making caesars with
vegetables he's what
that's what i'm asking i'm trying to say
that's not a caesar oh my
god i'm so sorry is there carrots in
your caesar salad i don't think so yeah
would you excuse me would you mind if i
just get a chance to do them again i'm
so sorry
i'm my apologies
hey guys orlando just two seconds
you stop look at me we're not serving
caesar's salad with bits of carrot in
there the caesar salad hasn't changed
come on guys radish
caesar salad then anything's missing the
[ __ ] flies
nerves are high and there's a lot of
confusion back there a lot of confusion
on the solid area tonight you have to
watch what he's doing
lucky's very complicated
complicated
what my gran could do better
and she's dead oh my god
we can't even get out of the trap
properly the cold food is backing up the
kitchen and this right now doesn't look
good
[ __ ] how it's 40 minutes into service
and not one proper salad has left the
kitchen can you help please yes and not
surprisingly customers patience is
wearing thin this lettuce is a futon
the kitchen's totally backed up i can't
even get a caesar salad caesar salad is
the simplest things to do you just put a
little lettuce in little you know it's a
god
unbelievable unbelievable unbelievable
i asked for five caesar salads like half
an hour ago where the [ __ ] are
do i have to make it myself by making
myself yeah oh
a caesar [ __ ] salad we're dying over
here come on hallelujah i got my
scissors
okay here is the dude
the kitchen is recovered from the salad
dilemma beautiful let's get these going
and an hour into service entrees are
making their way to the dining room and
relaunch looks to be back on track
oh my god just start working but the old
equipment at the restaurant has brought
the kitchen to a standstill
no no try to put it on the pilot guys
come on i'm [ __ ] believable if we
don't have the right equipment with that
kind of business at the same time we
can't respond give it to me
all right how can you work with a range
that half of it doesn't work
unbelievable they can't get a [ __ ]
meal out of here let's go
[ __ ]
oh
this relaunch we have to make it work we
don't have time to have another bad
night but we don't have what we need
back there to
really pull this off 100
while chef ramsay goes to the dining
room to see how customers are doing the
chefs continue to tinker with faulty
equipment
unaware that they are about to cause a
much bigger problem
something's burning bobby i smelled
something burning where do you smell
that
smell it
something is burning something is
burning over here
what is burning bread burning no it's
more than bread something else is
burning something is burning
i smell something burning something's
burning
[Music]
water water
no no no it's not watch out watch out
flip it away clear it away let's go
moving guys move the pan move the can
all right
within minutes of chef ramsay leaving
the kitchen to check on the dining room
something is burning over here a
stovetop fire has erupted putting the
relaunch and the restaurant in danger
as the smell of smoke enters the dining
room watch out please guys watch out
chef ramsay returns to the kitchen and
takes charge if it hits the pilot light
and backspines it's going to blow on his
legs or flow in his face
underneath is underneath watch out watch
out
get out
watch out guys please throw it away
clear it away when was the last time
that was clean
[Music]
chef ramsay got the fire out now we're
trying to get reorganized and back on
track i need one len medium rare one
rebuy medium rare come on guys
pull together let's go despite being
down to only six burners in the kitchen
finally an order out okay
andy and orlando have led a comeback
i'll see you veal chop lamb chop that's
it and fleming has rebounded from the
fire
people were extremely responsive to the
new menu they loved the items they were
socializing and having a good time it
was more noise than i've heard in this
restaurant in 15 years it's just
refreshing to see it this way
are you ready for dessert the chocolate
mousse we want one of everything oh very
good
the dessert trolley was sensational and
everyone loved the desserts there's
nothing left behind nothing to box no
swans cheers to you thanks thank you
success of your new restaurant he'll be
the best thank you very much thanks so
much
[Music]
okay guys
come over please
it was a tough night it was a successful
night but the oven slowed up service so
it's going to be very difficult to
produce
this new menu or any menu for that
matter with the equipment we have
yeah what a night
what a significant difference wasn't
there a new energy in the dining room
tonight a sort of vibe of yeah people
were alive
yeah we energized any one of you could
have thrown in the towel and given up
and you held your own
and i i i believed in the passion
and the fight and the determination to
make this ration work
thank you sir
that was good news
but
there's a big problem here yeah
this problem will prevent fleming's from
being a success
[Applause]
i need you to follow me
all of you please
i was scared and i wanted to get away
because i had no idea what was going to
happen
hurry up please come out hurry up stand
over there please
oh dear tonight
i was forced to make an emergency call
and this
is a result of that call
[Music]
[Applause]
a state of the art brand new tailor-made
vulcan kitchen when that tarp came off i
just felt this whole sense of relief
this was amazing this was the missing
link
oh my god
that's one of the most beautiful thing
i've ever seen in my life that's too
much wow that's for us come on
we're starting off with a unique six
ring burner a convection oven phenomenal
followed by a six burner diamond cut
char grill and then finally the most
amazing friar i'm very
[ __ ] happy
it's been installed tonight now you have
no excuse wow no excuse andy suzanne you
have everything you need inside that
restaurant now law staff great decor
great chef great menu and a new kitchen
now
take it and run with it
thank you so much
i
um
i'm just
i can't express myself well thank you
thank you so much i never in my wildest
dreams imagine we would be given so much
what am i doing thank you very much
there's absolutely hope for fleming's we
are going to make ramsay proud and we're
going to do it for ourselves too well
done for tonight thank you really well
done thank you yes yes yes fresh on tour
because that's what you showed thank you
now do it i will
good luck thank you make it work thank
you good night good night
chef ramsay did a lot of what was
necessary to get this restaurant on
track he really found the right idea and
the right design i i think it's gonna
save us i think it's gonna turn us
around
wow what a week out of all the kitchen
nightmares i've ever done this has to be
the biggest transformation ever we
completely changed the decor completely
changed the menu but the biggest change
of all was in the owner andy
now he can make his own history as
opposed to buying somebody else's
my goodness
caesar salad with carrots
unreal
groupon
[Music]
after chef ramsay left andy and his
loyal staff embraced the changes that
gordon put in place
wow ready to use
and with a brand new kitchen
and a new lease on life oh yeah that's
the sound like they're looking for
fleming has once again become the place
to eat like it was 20 years ago i can
run a restaurant i just needed to fire
back your menu looks beautiful man
flemings is going to be around for at
least another 20 years hi welcome to
fleming's have a seat we'll be right
there i think we're going to be on the
right track
you